[Music]
on this thursday night one month in and
no end in sight ukraine's fierce
resistance to russian forces either we
go to the end or we will die fighting
america's lying in the sand we would
respond and canada's role in reducing
the reliance on russian oil breaking
news the crtc's decision on a major
telecom takeover making history the
first black woman nominated to the u.s
supreme court and why republicans are
taking aim
plus rejecting the royals you want our
kids
to come and line up
and worship you
jamaica's push to dethrone the queen as
head of state
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jackson proskow
this is the grim scene in the city of
mariupol today as desperate residents
line up for aid surrounded by the
charred remains of their bombed out
homes
hi there and thanks for joining us
exactly one month ago russia launched
its unprovoked invasion of ukraine
unleashing devastation on innocent
civilians and threatening global
security as we know it today in brussels
nato leaders held an extraordinary
meeting to address the crisis and they
heard a direct plea for military aid
from ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky who delivered this dire warning
i'm sure you understand that russia does
not have any intention of stopping in
ukraine it does not think of it and will
not it wants to further against eastern
members of nato the baltic states poland
for sure will nato then stop thinking
about it stop worrying about how russia
will react
how can you be sure of that
ukrainians have mounted a surprisingly
fierce resistance and tonight as the war
enters its second month they're looking
to the west to keep up the fight against
russia we begin with jeff semple in
levite
after one month of war ukraine's
hardest-hit cities appear apocalyptic a
bird's-eye view shows the city of
mariupol before russia's invasion
and after
a resident recorded this video of his
attempt to escape the port city
including images too graphic to show of
a body lying in the road with gunfire
echoing through deserted streets
the warmer weather has now thawed the
ground enough for survivors to begin
burying the dead including this woman's
stepfather mr minion
he'd been injured and another man
offered to drive him to hospital but
then the car was attacked and blown up
she says
the un says four weeks of war have
killed nearly a thousand civilians
including around 100 children along with
an unknown number of ukrainian soldiers
there are a lot of military cemeteries
in europe full of soldiers including
canadians who serve during the first and
second world war but it is rare to see a
military cemetery
with graves so freshly dug as this one
all of these soldiers have just been
buried here they were killed in the
fighting over the past month against
russia and as you can see their faces
their birth dates some as young as 21
years old it's tragic this canadian
ukrainian lives in levive and just
buried her friend 38 year old igor
killed in the fighting almost a month
ago his body was just recovered and
returned to his home city
she's not sad she says she's angry
i believe that many ukrainians also feel
this sort of rage and they're not going
to give up they said
now is the time
either we go to the end
or we will die fighting
and that fighting spirit is paying off
the ukrainian navy released this video
of a russian ship in the black sea
gutted by flames and explosions ukraine
claims it was destroyed
elsewhere the ukrainian military is
pushing back retaking territory near the
capital kiev thanks in part to weapons
from the west but ukraine says that
firepower is running out the west should
be delivering more if they don't want to
take part in the war
get involved as they say then for god's
sakes give us the weapons give us the
tools
and we'll do the rest that growing
optimism is palpable in levive near the
polish border which has so far been
mostly spared the scars of war this
guitarist is singing a popular ukrainian
song called everything is going to be
okay
few had expected ukraine could withstand
a russian invasion but after a month
it's not only standing but standing tall
jeff semple global news leve
at their summit nato leaders were
confronted with the realities of war
today and the risks vladimir putin might
go even further ukraine insists more
military aid is now a matter of life or
death and president zielinski told the
alliance to stop being afraid of how
russia might respond
david aiken reports from brussels on how
much support the west is willing to
offer
extraordinary summits for extraordinary
times the most
serious
security crisis in the generation prime
minister justin trudeau joined u.s
president joe biden and other nato and
g7 leaders in talks on next steps to
isolate russia protect ukraine and plan
for what they called a reset of the
defense of europe the russian invasion
president putin's invasion of ukraine
has changed our security environment
for the long term it's a new reality
it's uh it's a it's a new normal
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
joined nato and g7 leaders via video
conference and he was blunt
you have thousands of fighter jets he
said but we haven't been given one yet
you have at least 20 000 tanks ukraine
asks for one percent of all your tanks
but nato is not giving up any tanks or
planes though it will provide more
anti-tank weapons and air defense
systems trudeau promised canada would
provide more lethal equipment in the
coming weeks and he also announced 55
million dollars in humanitarian aid
meanwhile some nato allies are boosting
defense spending to meet the new russian
threat security does not come for free
and doing war will cost more trudeau
said canada understands that we will
continue to be increasing our defense
spending but he provided no details we
continue to have those discussions at
home we have a budgetary process
underway right now the trudeau
government will also seek to find a way
for canada to increase food production
at home and abroad this illegal war in
russia
and its impact both on ukraine
and on russia
is going to
lead to real challenges around food
security in the world and it's certainly
something that
as leaders we are united on wanting to
address
canada did levy some new sanctions today
against more russians canada also
tightened export rules when it comes to
russia but canada is being asked to do
more the next time nato leaders meet it
will be in june in madrid and every nato
leader including justin trudeau is
expected to show up at that meeting with
precise details about how they'll
increase military spending and provide
more military aid to the nato mission
here in europe
jackson david aiken in brussels thanks
david
sanctions and nato's military buildup
have not been enough to pressure
vladimir putin to change course but for
the first time nato leaders say the use
of chemical biological or nuclear
weapons by russia would be a red line
and provoke a direct response heather
urex west reports on nato's strategy and
whether it will force russia to back
down with the meeting of nato the g-7
and the european union in one day
western allies are hoping to show a
strong and united front but while
western forces will remain on the
sidelines of this conflict for now there
were veiled warnings thursday that could
change if the russian president crosses
a line any use of chemical
weapons will totally change the nature
of the conflict it will be a blatant
violation of international law and
it will have
wide spread consequences the u.s has
been warning for weeks now russia could
be planning a chemical weapons attack in
ukraine it's now set up a so-called
tiger team a group of security experts
at the ready should chemical biological
or nuclear weapons be deployed we would
respond we would respond if he uses it
the nature of the response would depend
on the nature of the use the use of such
weapons of mass destruction would put
people well beyond ukraine's borders at
risk it's why nato's top military
commander has now activated the
coalition's chemical biological and
nuclear defense elements with allies
agreeing to supply equipment to ukraine
to help with detection protection and
medical support there is a visceral
horror of the use of these weapons of
mass destruction
i think that if putin were to
engage in anything like that
the consequences would be very very
severe i think we are at this pivotal
moment and uh
just from what we know of putin and his
strategy he needs to be able to declare
that he has won in some way and that's
looking harder and harder in terms of
the ground campaign
and the risk of escalation intensifies
as this conflict rages on heather urex
west global news washington
soldiers from quebec are the latest to
join nato's collective defense in europe
about 80 troops left quebec city last
night for latvia as part of operation
reassurance they're joining more than
300 canadian armed forces personnel
already in the region and 40 more are
expected to fly out later
and at the same time canadian soldiers
have been banned from going directly
into ukraine to help fight russia the
chief of the defense staff general wayne
eyre gave the order it applies to both
full-time members and part-time
reservists the only exception is if air
specifically approves their presence in
ukraine before the war canada had 250
military trainers there they were sent
to poland just prior to the invasion and
re-tasked with providing humanitarian
support
boris romanchenko the 96-year-old
ukrainian holocaust survivor killed in a
russian attack on his apartment building
has been laid to rest
a small group of relatives gathered to
pay their final respects including his
son
ronchenko lived through the nazi
occupation of ukraine he survived four
concentration camps and devoted his life
to preserving the history of the
holocaust romanchenko died friday
well as the world moves away from
russian oil and gas canada's energy
sector is rushing to step in as a
friendly alternative they're ramping up
production of fossil fuels for export to
the u.s and europe as abigail beeman
explains it's still not enough to offset
what russia produces
the west is clear it wants to stop
dependency on russian oil but actually
doing so is more complicated european
countries have been asking canada for
help what we can do in the immediate
term is very limited just because we
didn't invest much since 2014 in the
canadian industry thursday canada
announced it can increase oil and gas
production by the end of 2022 up to two
hundred thousand barrels of oil a day
and up to one hundred thousand
equivalent barrels of natural gas we
recognize that replacing russian oil and
gas in the short term
is going to be important canada can play
perhaps a modest role in that
but
our commitment
to reaching net neutrality by 2050 to
hitting
our climate commitments by 2030
remains as firm as ever
modest in the face of russia which
produces 10 million barrels a day
canada's 300 000 would flow through
existing pipelines down to the u.s gulf
coast the natural resources minister
says some may be used by the u.s to
offset russia the rest will be shipped
to the international market mainly
europe the government stresses this
won't impact canada's climate goals
environmentalists disagree those two
things cannot exist at the same time we
cannot
increase our oil and gas production
while also meeting our climate goals in
the long term they can start now but
they should have thought of this seven
years ago conservatives blame a lack of
liberal investment in the sector now we
need output now we need workers and we
don't have either because of their
actions we are paying the price while
the u.s and allies discuss the
possibility of a further release of oil
from storage to help calm markets with
respect to
the emergency stockpile these are
ongoing discussions and all those tools
are certainly on the table while
increasing production to help europe is
the immediate goal canada and allies are
firm that a transition to clean energy
and renewables are the medium and
long-term goals the liberals trying to
convince people they can do both abigail
beeman global news ottawa
north korea carried out a test of what
may be its largest intercontinental
ballistic missile yet
its military has fired multiple missiles
in recent weeks but today's icbm
launched appeared to be newer and more
powerful than its last test five years
ago the missile flew longer and further
than previous launches before crashing
into japanese waters south korea
conducted its own missile tests
immediately after in retaliation a move
that violates u.n security council
resolutions
to approve or not to approve
coming up the decision on whether to
allow the mega merger between rogers and
shaw
canada and britain launched free trade
talks in ottawa today in an effort to
deepen ties already worth 42 billion
dollars
we want to make it easier for british
and canadian businesses of all sizes to
trade with one another by breaking down
some of the non-tariff barriers that
some small and medium-sized businesses
feel have held them back
canada's trade minister mary ing says
negotiations are an opportunity to make
sure everyone benefits from trade
including underrepresented groups the
first round of negotiations begins on
monday pei farmers could soon resume
exporting potatoes to the u.s after
canada suspended shipments over potato
wart as part of the deal with the u.s
department of agriculture there are
still some restrictions potato wart
poses no threat to human health but can
reduce crop yields the pei potato board
says the export ban imposed in late
november cost island farmers more than
25 million dollars
and canada's broadcast regulator has
conditionally approved roger's 26
billion takeover of shaw a major step
forward in a merger that could reshape
the country's telecommunications sector
in its ruling the crtc outlined several
requirements including annual reports on
rogers pledge to bolster local news
coverage and a 27 million dollar
contribution to canada's broadcasting
system the takeover still needs the
approval of two other government
regulators
the judge who could make history in
america's highest court ahead the
partisan pushback in the way
you're watching global national
[Music]
well history is unfolding in the u.s
tonight where for the first time a black
woman is set to be appointed to that
country's supreme court
like so much of american life the court
is deeply divided down political lines
and kitenji brown jackson has found
herself at the center of a deeply
partisan battle reggie chichini joins us
from washington on this final day of
confirmation hearings reggie
jackson this is a moment of history
playing out in real time a judge katanji
brown jackson following a path blazed by
the women elevated to the supreme court
both past and present but if confirmed
she'll become the first black woman on
the highest bench in the united states
it fulfills president joe biden's
campaign promise one that was met with
predictable partisan charges that aim to
link this nomination with a far left
progressive movement for more than 20
hours over the course of the week judge
jackson was subjected to questions over
previous judicial rulings to which some
republicans alleged bias to defendants
race and gender issues were also used as
political ammunition leaving jackson
almost exacerbated at times i am not
importing my personal views or policy
preferences i am questioning your
discretion your judgment that's exactly
what i'm doing oh you wouldn't say that
you're an activist judge i would not say
that judge jackson earned our highest
rating well qualified for an appointment
to the supreme court now that last
remark comes from the american bar
association on thursday who lined up
with democrats in promoting judge
jackson's record as one whose decisions
that could be generational being
beneficial to both the court and the
country even though polling from earlier
this year shows the majority of
americans view the supreme court as one
that's motivated by partisanship now for
all the political posturing there's not
much republicans can do to stop
jackson's confirmation at this point
democrats can use their slim majority to
confirm her something that will cement
her place in the history books but not
change the conservative majority on the
court
jackson reggie shakini in washington
thanks reggie
next the country cutting off the crown
after a royal couple's royal backfire
queen elizabeth marked a historic
70-year reign last month now she marks a
first in the fashion world gracing the
cover of vogue magazine a young
elizabeth will be featured on a special
cover for british vogue's april issue
part of a special tribute to the
monarch's platinum jubilee
the issue arrives just weeks before she
celebrates her 96th birthday
but not everyone is celebrating the
monarchy these days especially in the
caribbean jamaica is the latest country
planning to sever ties with the
commonwealth following an earlier
decision by barbados the surprise
announcement came during a visit to the
island by prince william and the duchess
kate and as mike drollay explains their
royal tour brought back painful memories
in the former british colony
there was never a sense meeting the
jamaican prime minister would be
anything more than a photo op for the
duke and duchess of cambridge they
signed a guest book received a gift
before nodding politely as andrew
holness dropped this bombshell we are
moving on
and we intend to
attain
in short auto development
and fulfill our true ambitions
as an independent
development prosperous
culture will kate's tour commemorating
the queen's platinum jubilee was
intended to be a reminder to belize
jamaica and the bahamas about their
special connection to the monarchy not
to dredge up memories of colonialism and
slavery
yet every attempt to work their royal
charm has fallen flat a soccer match
played in khakis was openly ridiculed as
was the image of the royals shaking
hands with children through a fence
i think it just shows the depths to
which
you know people feel no particular
connection
to this institution other than the
question of
well when are you going to pay back what
you owe removing queen elizabeth as head
of state will take time and a referendum
what jamaicans want now is an official
apology along with reparations much more
than the remorse prince william showed
in a speech
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
you don't choose to apologize
you don't choose to ask for forgiveness
you don't choose to repay one penny
yet you want our kids
to come and line up
and worship you
this has to stop
there's no doubt that duke and duchess's
trip to the caribbean has been anything
but paradise they still have one more
stop on their jubilee journey the
bahamas which is shaping up to be
another royal pain
microlight global news toronto
and that's global national for this
thursday night i'm jackson proskow
tonight's your canada is this herd of
goats by the side of the road near
nordag alberta
we love seeing your canada please email
pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and i hope you'll
join us again tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]